thank you for calling me always sunny  podcast you're on with Rob Charlie and  Glenn  might have been here for the listeners  let's get hammered let's get hammered  about it  drink every single meal if I could I  comes from Justice do you officially  brains I wrote a altar boy load wipe  down boy I'll give you a man's point for  that  [Music]  hello Mr Spielberg hi is this Caitlin  yeah I love when you throw me out of a  window dad wants to do a reveal here he  goes and they need to tell you a secret  put into your mouth oh they're really  letting us improvise a lot of grass give  us  I've been listening and it seems like  it's been dumb for a bit nothing worse  than a podcast on video I love you guys  and I love you too  [Music]